blogging is the digital equivalent of
being a legacy writer what is a Blog
it's your website you think you're the
important part there's a saying I love
repeating to writers in chip 30 which is
you are not the main character of your
story the reader is the main character
the moment you realize that you realize
that you are in the business of serving
the reader that is literally what you
are being paid to do and so a Blog what
is that it's the writer going I'm super
special here's my fonts here's my
website here's my writings here's my
color scheme here's my pictures right
the reader doesn't care about any of
that point a they care about what you
can do for them point B is there's no
distribution flywheel so how is anyone
going to find your writing the only
people who know your about your website
or your blog or your mom and your dog